hey youtubers this charlie Doctor Who
week continues with my list of top 5
guest actors from current whoo that's
everyone from series 1 to now I might
also do a list from top 5 guest actors
from classic ooh - be sure to subscribe
to get all the rest of my videos this
week remember me and my friends are
doing videos every day for the Doctor
Who 50th anniversary number 5 Derek
Jacobi so he played the human form
version of the master as dr. Yanna
and he wasn't this crazy power-hungry
mad scientist he was just someone trying
to save his people from extinction at
the end of the universe I felt like his
performance was so great that you
sympathize with him so completely before
you find out his true identity so it's
his actual professor Yana persona that
made me put him on this list not so much
his make on the master number for
Michael Sheen
so Michael Sheen is one of the best
character actors that I can think of
right now he slips into roles so
completely that you almost forget who he
is and his episode was a Neil Gaiman
episode to boot so not only is the
doctor's wife one of my all-time
favorite Doctor Who episodes it's also
one of my favorite appearances by guest
star so Michael Sheen it's really only
his voice in the episode but the range
he goes from from clawing to terrifying
is just so amazing as this awful house
character the first time I saw the
episode I actually didn't realize that
it was Sheen's voice until I saw the
credits that's how well he was able to
slip into this role number 3 Simon Pegg
so Simon Pegg is on a bit of a tear
right now with the Cornetto trilogy and
all the Star Trek movies but before all
that he had been a lifelong fan of
Doctor Who so you would think that when
he got to be on the show he would have
just a little too much fun and it would
kind of overpower the role but he
actually played one of the most
compelling and realistic villains on a
Doctor Who series he played this
devilishly evil TV editor who cut things
to manipulate viewers which is not too
far off from what happens today in
reality TV I really enjoyed the fact
that he played this evil person as this
kind of casual and sweet character I
think there's a saying that says
something like the devil won't come as a
demon he'll come as a friend baring
falsely and that's kind of the way I
feel about reality TV so my number 2
choice is actually a bit of a funny one
but I wanted to include it on the list
because of its relevance to the 50th
anniversary so number 2 and Robinson as
Android in bad wolf
so mostly bad wolf you need to re-watch
because it's going to be big in the 50th
anniversary bad wolf is going to be a
big part of the 50th
bursaries the great thing about Ants
performances is that it's so dark and
you hate this character so completely
this Android character on this TV show
another TV show like simon Pegg's
character that by the time she shows up
in a later episode and gets killed by a
Dalek you cheer the Dalek for killing
her and any time a character can make
you root for your worst enemy I think it
is just amazing who else felt a little
conflicted for cheering for that Dalek
and my number one current Doctor Who
guest star Timothy Dalton as president
Rassilon the Dalton had the task of
playing one of the greatest Time Lords
who ever lived or who still lives
technically Rassilon is immortal beyond
the need for regenerations so he
basically had to make you believe like
the doctor had no chance against him and
the doctor is basically the greatest
Time Lord who ever lived
Dalton's performance ended up being so
charismatic that I was actually cheering
for him during part two at the end of
time to the end of time wait no no
that's bad no we don't want that
but since Doctor Who is so amazing at
pulling in great guest actors let me
know who your alternate top five are in
the comments below remember I had to
leave off people like Alex Kingston I
really should have done a top ten but I
didn't want this to turn into like a 20
minute video so coming up this week
tomorrow I'm doing my top five
companions then Thursday I'll be doing
my top five actors to play a doctor and
then on Friday I'll be posting my review
of an adventure in space and time as
well as announcing the winners of my
Doctor Who 50th anniversary giveaway
I'll have details about that in the
description but make sure to subscribe
to get all those videos also don't
forget about our 50th anniversary
pre-show livestream that'll be on
Saturday at 2:30 p.m. Pacific time
that'll probably be on the BBC America's
channel but I'll add a link in the
description as soon as they post a link
right now be sure to check out some of
the other awesome Doctor Who videos my
friends are doing this week by clicking
on some of these annotations here thanks
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you